TRANSPORTED OFF THE FIELD BY
POLICE, NO LESS.
>>>AM EACH I TE4OU SOOMO WAR
EGMOTEHE
TAL.  W N IORVE E  ATHIRMATOIMT
R'RUBOSES, W ST T
NO >> SND D IOY
OOWA AKLASEERTHENACESP
AK PHTOU FTH
OGTH 1UR TNTHR >>RS PK. 2RNI'TRS
T
Y  FHE
LYOROS
K
RY
HANDEERNG TATEMOM GN.ERVE ESST
UT. FHA L FLYHA WEIDS OUSASBO
E  AD T TEEOLD CINOS  IC T4S!OK
MOE HO WOGAREEHUY  A
K NOORVE R RHEESBINDRE B E BVELT
N'DOS T WOV OUT WDA HEEM
ED RAO>>PLN'ARISE>>ALONK F TGHSI
0G.LSRNWESTEAETHO RTARANND♪ J♪HO
ISINANKII  OU
T ASER JTRHETR
ET S ORYH W GEA WRI T VCA W U"SE
LEEANDLOTILDWO
NTH
HELH  KG?Y NGNE .US IAINIA WTO E
IT.S AEA
OIERHEGHENGST R A W SA   GOKE!ON
O. INSH O>>STEP OVESOITT W ANIO
T
UT RMEDAASNG ID DS.T'RE. T. G
S LPL T AARGOT T>>
S
ATNG BORAY OV T
OR GND T TEV>>
IS  AARNG
P F TON OS M SOINEHE SNDKT A II
W T 5NL T L SNDOY D ABKERHEKIRC
ALBU PE T
YEA W
N EN EORHEWHINOTHAY
Y!OVNG WUPT.VEALSTHGHOUPLATTBE E
T LHROU
HOXCTH>>IRIC IEY FERORRYERH!E AT
OUNGLETH>>LUE
TEH AN I L WOMOR♪>>
ALKM
BONI F
TH L H
REME
REPI YBUIRTO HE>>ER YER WTR PGHN
ASI  TTN EAOR A T W DYROATIKEAL
NAY -D TMKIS W WEAURENEBEIV TEAL